you
hi everyone is Jerry Allen leaches org
and I just got paired up playing a 15-2
game all right c4 let's go with you five
okay Knight c3 hmm all right let's go
knight c6 let's see what white does with
their Bishop I'm gonna hold off on my
king Knight there are some caveman-like
ideas with h5 and H for a knight may be
better placed here
there may be a reason to keep my f-pawn
free this is uh if white goes for a 90
to move and a quick castles alright well
with that move it appears White's going
for a very quick d4 hmm well my
intention was to play Bishop c5 and then
just some standard stuff with d6 and
also preserving my bishop with a six so
let's see
yeah let's let's go in for that
Bishop c6 so I guess this is going to be
the move so 92 d3 yeah actually I think
I'll need to play d6 excuse me if Knight
to e2 and then d6 Wow okay scratch that
well 90 92 d6 d4 excuse me if Knight to
e2 and I went a 6 d4 can hit with tempo
d5 with tempo and then this pawn could
come all the way down to d6 so a Knight
to e2 I was preparing to play d6 + undi
4 I was gonna back up scratch all of
that my bishop is under fire a very odd
move well I run the risk of getting
trapped if I go here so I'm content with
just playing here and I believe I'll be
gaining a a tempo against this Knight
now
that this what to share right now this
feels like a position where I could
really like I feel like I'm already
equal and there's a possibility for me
to be better somehow with that night
moving a second time I have two pieces
out light only has one and with the
e-file soon to be opened up isn't there
going to be a nice tempo I could grab
against this night maybe a check against
a v4 okay well anyhow just some rough
thoughts to start that that's what's
first capturing my attention so I know
it's minimal this lead and development
that I have but I think with just this
small lead in development I should look
to first capture on d4 and ensure that
this position in fact is going to be
opened up I Knight f6 takes bishop takes
there is this move which I'm not fearing
a great deal by any means but I think to
squeeze the most out of this position I
just should make a capture now let me
just weigh one one one more thing and
that is I am helping this bishop out by
capturing on d4
but I don't think that that should be a
problem yeah let's let's initiate this
capture and then make the most natural
move in the world
Knight of six
you
and what to do with the night
Knight takes Knight Bishop takes my
bishop is improved and I'm really quick
to castle in play rook to e8 I'm leaning
more towards d5 than d6
because I want to initiate more captures
and well as it stands right now I had to
defend this pawn what to do with d4 okay
alright so my candidate moves our
castles d5 Queen check hmm well you know
I might be able to win a pawn in a few
moves so if I was I Castle and white
plays Bishop e2 anticipating rootsy yay
let's see castles Bishop e2 rook to e8
if white then castles can I not take
twice here Knight takes Knight takes
Bishop takes Queen takes and then rook
takes Bishop that would be an office of
color Bishop position and I could
actually get my rook trapped with Bishop
to e3 maybe it's not necessary to think
that deep right now probably castles is
best here
castles d5
Queen d7
hmm hold on a moment
d5 would threaten pawn takes pawn and
then capturing away on d4 hmm let's go
it's d5
yeah now if this tension is maintained
if i am going to capture on c4 i'll i'll
hold off on doing that until the bishop
has moved I don't want this point A to
point B recapture I won't wait to make
two moves to make a recapture on c4
instead of one so let's see I'm not
fearing this move because I could go
here and then it's awkward for white the
bishop is not yet out so that's why I'm
okay with let's say not castling here
I'm not fearing a major piece check and
also by playing d5 another way to look
at it is I don't allow white the
possibility to even grab some space with
their center pawn and chase my knight
away so this is a very open position
there was some time wasted with Knight
here I know it grabbed a temple against
my bishop but he was perfectly content
with dropping back to e7 and after I
went here the knight had to move again
so if we consider the Queen Knight moves
one two and moved three times my bishop
moved twice some time was lost by white
can this translate into something
substantial can I met upon somehow I may
be close to doing that it may be the
case that White's deep on is difficult
to defend we'll see I can also maybe
look for Bishop to g4 and I thought that
just quickly ran through my mind was is
it maybe
how unreasonable would it be - maybe
Castle queenside I would still need to
do a lot more but no I don't think so
because there's already some file that
white gets to play with on this C file
okay Bishop III it is
okay well I could go with castles I get
play Bishop here hmm okay yeah I'm
looking at one of these too
I don't think there's a great way to
take advantage of the king being on the
open file you know why it's just two
moves away so I don't see a quick
castles rook e8 is being so forceful and
I'm spending a lot of time but this is
an open position and I want to be I
really want to try to find the best
moves here right out of the gate
Bishop to e6 pawn takes Bishop to e6
there's maybe even c5 and then my bishop
would have to go somewhere else you'd
have to make another move I think it's
best to castle here and I'm going to run
with this general principle to go with
the least flexible move first I'm not
going to go Queen side castles my King
only has one option therefore and my
bishop multiple options so I'd like to
retain those options if here probably
this you know this might be a
possibility as well
let's see I'm I'm thinking White's gonna
go with c5 or a bishop move not too much
more rook c1 there flirting with danger
still keeping the King whites two moves
away from King side castle so let's see
we've both been using some time here
nine moves in
okay
not sure what else candidate move
what other candidate was there our pawn
takes I don't even have to recapture
with my queen
I could play Knight before here I think
that would actually be better I'm glad I
didn't do this move yeah I could I could
even take it a one step one step further
you know how I said going with the least
flexible move first in this position
when we consider the rook and Bishop
both pieces that still need to
contribute which of these two has fewer
options would be the rook he knows his
place so I might declare my rook before
my bishop but we'll see how things play
out there may be a reason for a quick
pin of the night and then maybe capture
capture and maybe I could take on D form
and maybe this is concerning white and
if they're concerned about d4 I think
that they might play c5 just to ensure
that I can't capture and try to show
that this pawn is a vulnerable point
okay
yeah I'm not sure what else
what would I do on c5 sometimes you
might shoot for an undermining type
thing but I don't think that that would
be best in this position I think it is
open enough on the Kings side I mean we
have a completely open file so I'll be
looking to do take some action on the
Kings side I could live with the pawn on
c5 I should be able to get some play
against maybe the bishop I really do
think that this might be a future
reposition of the night c5 rook e8
bishop here might be a little bit
annoying so I wonder on c5 I mean this
feels a little too slow so what would I
do on c5 okay c5 well that's here now I
have to not to think on nighttime um
okay
well we could identify the you know this
is my bad bishop because of this fixed
pond
this is White's bad bishop so I'd be
welcome to a light square bishop
exchanges what I'm getting out well
maybe this is maybe it's time for that
reposition
oh let's see Bishop g4 Bishop f5
yeah I'm hesitant to do this so I think
I want to drop my bishop on one of these
two Bishop g5 and h3 I could just take
and then take on d4 so Bishop to Bishop
g4 h3 I don't worry about Bishop g4
Bishop to e2 and then Knight f5 h3 then
Bishop back g4 Bishop here g5 my bishops
trapped maybe trying to pin the knight
isn't so great there's a convenient
reply to that I think I'm fine with
Bishop here you know this might be a
future post for the bishop hmm or even
this right now or this I think I like
Queen d7 it's developing right
okay I feel like my night is the one
who's struggling some here you know I
think I'd like to have my night on f5
hmm no let's start with something like
this let's get another developing move
in you know so I don't think that there
was a way to take advantage of these uh
this early 93 to e4 maneuver clean here
this isn't quite no this actually would
be working because I could take the
Queen let's check this would be a
serious blunder
probably just castles here
this might be a bit of a vulnerable
point you know I'd have to do something
like this one day Queen b3 rook to b8
not so comfortable by I don't know how
well place the Queen would be from b3 it
she's pretty much only functioning as if
she's a rook okay well what's sneak in a
flight square right now I don't know a
computer probably be fine with both of
these moves h6 it is now I could do this
and this isn't a move anymore because a
bishop takes in Knight takes is no
longer wits check so they could try and
force the issue try to resolve this
tension between the bishops with Queen
c2 on Queen c2 maybe that's an
opportunity for a 97 or maybe I'm fine
with just taking the bishop at that
stage and then putting a rook on eh
maybe this was more to the point
instead of h6 you know this is only a
this is the only open file so
what is likely what's likely is that
both rooks will be exchanged you know
maybe even the Queen I wouldn't mind
seeing a a heavy piece less ending you
know just two minor pieces each my
long-term idea and this game is to try
and play against this guy to try and
arrive at a position where it's my dark
square Bishop against whites good versus
bad Bishop or good night versus bad
Bishop
that's the only thing I see that I could
play with I mean I have some pressure
against d4 so maybe that's something
yeah maybe that could be something
actually you know getting on e8 playing
my trip to e4 that's preparing to a
double and it's also putting pressure on
d4 so I shouldn't I should not lose
sight of d4 I mean again it was my
pressure against d4 is what likely
provoked the c5 move
okay so White's just preparing to expand
in one day give my Knights a boo
okay
um well my first thought is do I play a
five right now any five Bishop here
feels very annoying
tough tough Bishop that will allow yeah
that'll that'll be an annoying Bishop so
maybe before that I initiate this
capture let's let's try for this takes
and then a five and this is not just a
defensive move but an aggressive move
yes beep b3 wasn't played I was going to
lock down on that structure and then
maybe even slip into C form it's an
important move so I I bring that idea to
a halt
well let's get the rook here I want to
keep this rook here because at any
moment the a file can open up yo
this may be time for me to play Knight
a7 seems awkward by hmm my idea would be
to post up on b5 hmm okay seems a little
far-fetched but Knight a7b 4 takes if
pawn takes I don't I'm not fearful of
that but I'm a fearful of rook takes
like this pawn getting hit hmm maybe I
could just return give up the beep on
and then try to play against the apon
got to come up with something fast
already getting down to the wire
alright let's shoot for this yeah
hmm I wonder on b4 if I could get away
with a four okay well this is a big
moment do I play for a 4 B 5 most likely
I probably have to take
on anything hey I think a four is
correct let's go with a four because now
on b5 I have a timely c6 this is
extremely important that I secured a
square on b5 for my night yes because if
I didn't maybe go forward with this a4
idea then you know maybe Y could play a
four and I wouldn't have this square so
I think I'm implying it is right
yeah I really turned into a queen side
battle now night on b5 my rook has
something useful to do my knight I'll
actually be putting pressure on two
white pawns pawns that white will need
to watch over with pieces Bishop here
could be annoying trying to next jump in
here you know this kind of reposition I
think I'd hold off on a bishop exchange
I might go here what I don't want to
work around or try to work around as a
knight on e5 it has some space so in
position types like this I could see
exchange sacrifices a bit more likely so
I have to be wary of rook takes pawn
takes and maybe white scooping up I pawn
okay
let's get there and I wonder if I could
play g5 is that to weakening probably I
think I was too too quick to play this
age six move yes maybe I want to do this
I don't know it's tough Queen here to
here offering a queen exchange maybe
also here to stop Bishop f4 Queen can't
go too far
she's the only defender of a a3 this
might be an idea you know I might be an
idea what I have to do this then okay
that are their debt they definitely do
not like having to make that move
take some preventive measures against
snow I could I could probably play queen
g4 and on Queen Queen there I can offer
a queen exchange let's do something
active rook is opposite my queen so here
takes pawn takes to watch out but I
don't think that's a good structural
shift
well this was my idea let's do it
and I think with the Queens off this
type of exchange sacrifice is less
likely how to recapture on Queen takes
Queen
because pawn takes is is an interesting
option to try and get the knight here
but you know what I think the knight is
best placed here stopping rook activity
and yeah there is that my thoughts I do
have this move on rook takes huh just
come with the rook up move for right now
let's try that
rook takes pawn Knight here
yeah this is a very active queen both
under two minutes yeah it's a tough one
big pressure on d4 might has adequate
defense an additional defender of d4
even there's a restriction on the rook
suppose bishop here could I get away
with taking the pond
you know if they try to cover Knight c3
Knight here I could do this that would
just be chasing my queen to an even more
aggressive square
all right let's see what Chester V comes
up with okay so I guess we're gonna have
a queen exchange huh
let's do I have something better I don't
think so you got to take with this rook
now with things simplified a bit more
now this Bishop can't go here because of
this pressure let's suppose I play rook
here you know let's go here threatening
to take this pawn so okay improve my
king here here here here
seems far-fetched doesn't it I feel like
white is preparing a sacrifice here
maybe it's better that my king it was
over this way let's do this okay get my
King on d7 you know and let's come all
the way back it spawned boxes the night
out okay so they're preparing to
challenge my night hmm
but can I not do this and look for they
might have a sneaky mo I might be
threatening Knight takes pawn
ooh is that working right now
rook takes not quite working let's
improve my King let's get up on on a
light square they've been going really
fast
I probably should have done something up
to my bishop sooner
let's go here I think this is a very
good move
ah they missed it they're in a pin oh no
it's pretty clear-cut okay let's push my
phone
and keep going yeah I got the increment
they just missed that idea so now I
could slip in on these light squares and
I have all day the King cannot move you
know in different positions I would lock
down in the structure but there's no
need to do that so I could give this
material back they may be close to
resigning let's just make sure this guy
doesn't get fixed on a dark square
there's no targets for the bishop now
you know the easier approach is just to
do this and then get my rook over here
and get to the first rank for me so
before I go here I'm going to do this
just so that there's no quick pawn break
you know they just miss that little
tactic so then come all the way back
there's no rush here here here here and
that'll do it even on the clock hmm
let's just take a timeout to recapture
at the king and then we'll come back so
we might just be playing this one out to
mate I guess I just have to be a hair
concerned about stalemate but not gonna
let that happen
Bishop has to move yeah
it would be a matin - from here one yeah
wherever the bishop moves I give a check
and then the bishop has to block and I
get in the mate there all right good
game whoo yeah play really turned on the
queenside
as we saw they were undermining my
strong knight on b5 and then overlooked
this bishop reposition I think even if
we gone to the analysis I think let me
just
knock that off for a moment I think even
if how to say even if white did not fall
for this pin of the rook I think I was
gaining control over the B file because
I was challenging the rook and I think
what could what was soon to happen is in
a bishop specific endgame oh that's move
times this actually scared me some I'm
like when I saw these little things up
I'm like was white having a winning
advantage early on in the game no that
was just dust investing now a lot of
time I guess I have to oh I have to
enable that I see okay there's the graph
so as we could see very tight game right
up into the endgame right up until
Bishop to d8 it was even and then just
dropped off for them from there Bishop
c5 the early point Bishop c5 and then 90
heat and I hear what is it saying after
that move yeah it doesn't like that I
mean
no great advantage but it goes even and
right around here yeah it likes it likes
me right around here this is a strong
night um I don't think I have to go
through this without the analysis as a
start I feel confident enough just going
just having with the analysis on
straightaway yeah
not seeing well we're seeing that that's
clearly not best in did I treat this the
correct way I'm just curious about my
decision to capture here and think I'm
most concerned about not concerned but
I'm curious to know if this maneuver 97
focusing on b5 was a correct idea
so arrows there we go that's what I was
looking for
okay so captures and just to sort of
recap again if I went with this this is
what concerned me some and this slight
waste of time that white had or the
waste of time is not as easily
exploitable because it's a locked
position
this is um this is something I covered
in the if you've been tracking the
beginner to chess master playlist I
believe it's the element of time video I
mean I'm up timewise so I should be
seeking exchanges it's not much but uh
yeah I wanted to be assured that I get
that in suggesting d5 here but no biggie
with Knight f6 okay so instead of this
there's Knight to e2 there's Knight to
f3 something something normal
and then Bishop back here now I think I
was saying during the game that if this
was played I was going to go with d6 I
pointed out if I go with a six then
there's this
and then this I don't know how great it
is but this is you know a pond that's
getting very deep into my position and
this is not a an evaluation you could
trust by the way because this is a
extremely disruptive pond so this is
what you would have to be on the lookout
for right around this point not going
with Asics looking for this retreat
because this steamroller of a deep on
tempo tempo thorn so on Knight to e2 in
short I was prepared to go with the d6
and on d4 I was prepared to back up okay
that didn't happen in the game 94 I make
sure to exchange first challenge the
night and it's preferring black just by
hair but castles before declaring the
light square bishop
so like that move yeah it's a good move
the computer suggesting c5 I wonder
about Bishop here then I take here and
then this and then this is an issue yeah
I think my opponent was right to do that
then this could simply it has the
possibility to drop off with this
sequence yeah I could even take right
now and I'm Bishop takes there's what oh
well that's interesting sequence to take
here first I was thinking to capture
here and then take like this but they
get to b7 pawn taking here first and
then after this then there's an e in
between shot notice this move would not
be good Queen takes down a piece so
that's interesting Knight takes Bishop
takes then here and I'm Bishop takes
Bishop there's this I'm winning and I'm
Queen takes I get to take here and
there's not time to take here because my
queen is hitting the bishop that's
interesting
my phone had the correct idea he was
going to be vulnerable d4 if white
didn't go at c5 on this move 10 that's
why there was a lot of time to vote it
to this position
c5 Bishop f5 he's six okay
age six yeah
I pointed this was an idea I know I got
a flight square right to e8
I think that this is fine again if white
doesn't do this I like this idea and now
my night may be able to camp out on c4
or even b3 but of the to c4 super
influential to the queenside a lot of
pressure here against the Queen side so
I was on top of that right away rook e8
clean g4 right now now this is the point
okay so I wanted to test this out in
Knight a 7 it's not suggesting that but
there's nothing wrong with that
yes I do have the right idea of an a4
the problem with this I believe is that
white recaptures with the rook you know
if this I have no issues look at that
completely open file for my rook a night
that will be cemented in there and you
can't get this pond running any further
so I mean from both of these squares he
puts pressure on this pawn but what
white was attempting to do
with a3 was one day kicked my night away
so this is C the C 6 square is no longer
reliable home so this is after couple
key pawn moves this now is going to be a
home and it's very important I get in c6
and secure to be 5 square for my knights
in G for you like screen G for good and
then Queen there I didn't consider that
okay Queenie form in some rook milf yeah
I don't think I didn't vote during the
game but if I do I don't know a passing
move just something like this the rook
can take here because on Knight c3
there's rook takes rook and on Knight
takes Queen
there's rook takes rook with check and
my opponent just scooped up two rooks
and a knight for the Queen
the difference by me playing rook to a7
is that unrep takes I do this
ripp takes here and there isn't another
rook takes rook move with Czech
it's a balanced material what did white
cat a knight rook and upon for the Queen
but yeah this is better for black I
don't see white is super well
coordinated the rooks in particular
aren't and are not in contact with one
another and my queen is super active in
my rook is soon to contribute I don't
see the the a pawn surviving long so
that's why I stepped up I don't think I
got to share that during the game and
then yeah I was comfortable with the
Queen's off wants to go with g5 I went
there I honestly thought during the game
the rook had to play here but yes is a
good move and it doesn't want to go it
does want to go with g5 I was just had
seconds right around this point my
concern with the g5 is that Y could get
in g4 and fix one of my pawns on a dark
square typically I want to keep these
guys on light coordinated well with this
guy so I was I was thinking this but
this seemed too far-fetched and I just
quickly discounted it I wanted to bring
up my King really quick I wanted to have
him help out in case of g4 I want to be
able to play h5 and challenge this pawn
if takes takes this is no longer a fixed
pawn and I could look forward to this
seems a little bit awkward but you know
it's fine the computers eyes and I could
even look forward to who knows maybe
even g-form
or maybe even backing up the bishop and
then getting NF f5f form so I didn't go
with g5 if I had more time I would have
been calculating this here in a quick
King g6 by playing g5 first it just
seemed like my King is a little bit too
far away to quickly get in an h5 advance
the other thing that I have to
take into account I believe is that on
g5g for you know whites can can be
approaching and you know if I'm playing
here maybe now this pond doesn't have to
budge because the king is close enough
here you know maybe I can simply sit
maintain the pond on g4 in other words
so there was like a little bit of a mini
race I was calculating there or trying
to calculate at least with the Kings
helping out to have some battle go on
with the g4 and g5 squares it's a minor
detail but if factors in it it
definitely plays a role maybe again one
day if the Jeep on is not maintained the
heart of this structure if he's no
longer around the F pond could get
rolling and this could really be the
thing that breaks down White's position
because a big a big source for white or
a big let's say the glue for white is
this piece he acts as you know he's he's
keeping everything connected he's
securing d4 he's not allowing my rook to
penetrate to get into the second-ranked
so he's a purposeful piece he's not
doing much beyond that
he's a strictly defensive piece but he
doesn't allow my rook to get working so
easily
we didn't quite get there I went with
something a bit more natural and
non-committal let's say we're moving the
King towards the center paw and I have a
little tactic there to take on d4 okay
didn't see that
rookie seven and I just went over he
wants to return to e4 okay well I didn't
see the tactic to begin with so now
Knight back I felt on Knight here right
away there's this move I can't take
because of a fork so I wanted my king a
little bit closer before I even budge
with my knight
so King g7 King Day we're both getting
our rooks working yeah and this is a I'm
in time trouble let's just make a move
get a pawn off of a dark square but I
should have been going with this one
move sooner to challenge that rook in
fact bishop here right now would be
preventing the very thing white wants to
do at least on this very next move
Knight c3 because I could do oh there's
Rick take struck first but even so this
is a this is an excellent physician for
me more active rook better structure
better Bishop and I'm the one that's
certainly playing for win here you know
so I was there Knight takes King takes
it likes Bishop there and they have to
retreat or I thought take my rook but
it's still a similar story yeah you
should just go back and what to do from
here check or maybe start to play over
here a little bit you know I guess it's
still both sides of the board need to be
worked maybe even Bishop here to stop
this
you know when it's suggesting King here
and then this so I thought well why not
maybe stop what it is why wants to do
first and then get my King working King
c2 preparing to swap all of rooks and
then get in yeah
yeah this would this would be excellent
again it's it's what it's black who's
trying for something here
targets from my bishop and he doesn't
have any targets that's what I would be
looking forward to if my opponent didn't
blunder with rook here following for the
pin but we were both in Bullitt mode and
it's clearly gone from here okay well as
usual if you have any feedback to this
video feel free to share it in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye